les habitants de port-au-prince ont
privés d'essence depuis un mois raison à
la guerre des gangs qui bloquaient
l'accès aux raffineries elle est de
retour mais la distribution se fait au
compte gouttes hier des gangs qu'ovide
maintenant l'assassinât du président qui
aggrave la situation économique
situation désastreuse et bien avant la
mort du plaisir à voir le communisme cet
ancien directeur de la banque centrale a
écrit un livre intitulé haïti une
économie de violence d'abord le taux de
change varie énormément parce qu'il y à
un taux officiel et un taux parallèle
due à une forte spéculation pour cette
une situation extrêmement précaire les
populations les plus vulnérables parce
qu'ils n'ont pas accès à l'eau la boue
n'ont pas l'eau passait là par amitié
ils n'ont pas de contact pour pouvoir
voir les voleurs hilla le ps de l'ariège
de guerre extrêmement important parce
que nous ne disons rien donc les
haïtiens sont assistés sont dépendants
de la diaspora les 3 milliards que l'on
reçoit de la diaspora c'est ce qui fait
fonctionner l'économie haïtienne m
[Musique]
quatre millions d'haïtiens sont en
situation de vulnérabilité alimentaire
et deux millions et demi en situation
d'urgence alimentaire
l'économie a été capturé par un groupe
de privilégiés au détriment de tous les
autres
ce n'est pas nouveau d'abord c'était les
vieilles grande famille puis les proches
des régimes successifs ils demandent
tous leur part du gâteau avec l'arrivée
de martelly ce sont des gens qui
faisaient partie du parlement donc pour
les sénateurs députés et ensuite des
gens liés aux gros clubs de ph et pl et
d'autres clans et politique ce sont eux
qui sont devenus si vous voulez les
nouveaux entrepreneurs politiciens comme
l'air les anciens ont été balayés ce
sans attendre politiciens qui ont des
contacts avec l'état et qui eux aussi il
existe des privilèges au niveau des
institutions de l'état la droite sénat
n'est pas en mesure la présidence de
joël moïse n'a rien arrangé
on continue d'assister au pillage
systématique des ressources et des fonds
propres de l'état même ceux qui sont
empruntés la corruption et général des 4
milliards de dollars avancée par le
venezuela dans le cadre du programme
petrocaribe et deux milliards et demi
ont disparu des projets ont démarré et
reste en chantier des ponts des routes
des stades
le nouveau parlement n'est toujours pas
bâti il n'ya que l'édifice du
stationnement
ceux qui ont protesté contre cet énorme
scandale de corruption ont été réprimés
par pour nous sommes en train d'assister
à l'implosion d'un état mafieux le
départ du président moïse aura au moins
donné l'occasion de tout remettre à plat
les premiers concernés sont ceux qui
vont former le gouvernement provisoire
jusqu'à des élections mais on sait déjà
que les principaux acteurs en ce moment
sont en profond désaccord sur la suite
des choses
jean michel leprince radio-canada port
au prince